There She Goes
breathing and breathing
there you go
44 degrees
we're gonna go to the Tucson gem show
and then we're going to go have dinner
with the first female combat fighter
pilot America's most courageous woman
yes and then you're happy oh yeah
uh yeah I wasn't expecting anything and
here we are so we got some new
decoration for the believe office let's
go
hello everyone happy Sunday happy Sunday
Evan happy Sunday what are we doing
today we're in Tempe which is like
Phoenix Arizona and we're driving to
Tucson to go to the world famous Gem
Show which happens once a year here it's
a full week today's the last day and we
got invited to go from uh Mr Joe polish
so we're on our way to go pick him up
and then drive two hours to
Tucson Tucson to the gem show we're
bringing the dogs with us so they're not
alone by themselves and we're hoping to
get some amazing
I don't know
staff please
and crazy time my amazing life let's go
we're waiting on our friend Joe polish
from genius Network we are at optimize
we're meeting up we're not going to
optimize today I don't think maybe but
we're meeting him here
's filming Joe for the Vlog he's got
some inspiring words to kick us off this
morning inspiring word so
um
if you want to be a better human then
you need to
um read my book
what's in it for them well and if you're
too cheap or too dumb or too incapable
of reading my book or listening to it on
audio then the question to think about
is what's in it yeah what's in it for
them that's a question to think about
whenever you interact with anyone
because uh you know like everybody uh
wants something uh you want something
but make sure that you show up thinking
about what they want because you have to
deal with people at the level at which
they respond and they usually respond to
what's in it for them not what's in it
for you
go team so apparently we're going to
after my first before we head down to
Tucson to see the gem so right we didn't
bring anything
yeah
let's go Evan let's go okay
[Music]
foreign
you've been in here for over a minute
how long are you planning to stay it's
nine minutes nine minutes no it's been
10 minutes it's been 10 minutes I don't
know 10 minutes in another minute
oh okay so it's almost nine minutes
okay so you're gonna stay here for 10
minutes
going in
here she goes
is timeline herself she's never done a
morning Plunge
There She Goes
breathing and breathe
here you go
four degrees
[Music]
all right we're done optimized I was
cold I stay in the cold plunge for over
six minutes Evan's staying there for 10
minutes right Evan yeah yeah how do you
feel
I feel good yeah I was sitting there for
22 minutes you guys should do nothing 22
minutes minus the 20 minutes right
we're gonna go to the Tucson gem show
and then we're gonna go have dinner with
the first female combat fighter pilot
America's most courageous woman yes and
uh Martha McSally she's awesome and uh
gonna see what you guys from Canada end
up buying me you know coming down
Arizona to my home state it's part of a
tradition is you go if you visit from
Canada to America and you go to the
Tucson gem show you have to buy at least
a hundred thousand dollars worth of
items for your guests I think that's how
it goes I picked that we'll have to look
that up online just to make sure
here we go watch out believe
we are in Tucson that we wanted to stop
for lunch or well they want to stop for
lunch and uh it's a friend of a friend I
guess so we're gonna have I think
Mexican food eventually we're gonna get
to the gem show I think you know we did
the we did the optimize we did the cold
plunge the sauna now we're doing lunch
and I think we're gonna hit the gem show
we'll see let's go
[Music]
so we're having lunch with Joe polish
and and America's most courageous woman
she is North America's best courageous
woman remember that what's your message
of the day people well my message of the
day is if you've not if you want to be
more courageous or at least get a little
bit of background on Martha read her
book get her to fly go to Amazon or
whoever books are sold right now and
order it that's the first thing and
secondly she'll probably get better
advice on how to live your life than I
am just going to tell you to read a book
so I have a lesson from walking boomer
this morning he often goes by houses
where there's dogs barking and and he
gets all worked up and he goes by the
house today and like the dogs aren't
even there but he's getting all worked
up and it's just like us as people like
we get afraid of stuff that maybe we've
been in similar situations before and so
right away we get to work up but if you
actually choose to do things afraid and
you push through that then you don't
have to be stuck in that cycle of fear
it can be great that's what I'm trying
to say
[Music]
and left at 8 30 and it's now 1 30. New
York and I think we're actually gonna go
see some gems next I think that's next
away
[Music]
okay I'm here with uh Martha she's going
to open up this very special
one-of-a-kind uh yeah
awesome there you go that's cool
courageous woman here we go that's
beautiful
be courageous that's right yeah
the whole thing and Nina never pressed
records that's great but wait ah okay
well anyways we are going to the gym
show right now earlier we were at the
African uh art show yeah
foreign
dogs so I'm just gonna stay outside with
the dogs
while they're inside enjoying the The
Gem Show
[Music]
well
we didn't like that place so
what happened well I'm Abe I I see dead
people and there was a lot of spirits
that are around there that seem to be
very dark and
um you know Evan really likes to do this
whole believe positivity thing and this
would have required him to dance with
the shadow himself a bit so I don't
think it was in the mood so I said let's
go to another location so hopefully this
is a better looking yeah that's what's
up that's what's happening
again no dogs
allowed
[Music]
I got this one for my office and then
Evan got this one
I haven't got this one for his office
are you happy oh yeah go would you want
it uh yeah I wasn't expecting anything
and here we are so we got some new
decoration for the believe office let's
go Joe what did you get uh it appears to
be a skull it may be real it may not be
real wow someone has to come to the
genius Network Headquarters to find out
because it'll be there that's what I got
yeah this is pretty much calling it a
wrap because this place is closing down
so it was cool it's fun and it was great
to see uh Evan by a bunch of Hello Kitty
uh crystals and stuff that was the best
part I didn't know you're into that Evan
both Hello Kitty and Crystal separately
but you combine them and it's a whole
new world they'll blow your mind yeah he
manifested that he manifested that
believe
next up we're gonna go to uh Joe's
favorite restaurant
Ethiopian restaurant apparently he said
this could this was gonna make you very
gassy and we have two hours right home
five people in the car yeah
all right
and uh you want me to highlight the day
well it's been a long day uh I was
having to teach Evan all about uh Ai and
I'm kidding well he's he knows a lot
about AI so we're having a discussion
with that we have arrived back we are
safe and sound the Tucson gem show was
awesome the Ethiopian food was awesome
if given the choice of hanging out with
Nina or Evan Nina's way more pleasant
and has a much more positive attitude
than those of you that follow Evan with
believe could probably tell that already
but all I know it was a good day what
did you guys think
it's always special spending time with
Joe polish that's right you could tell
the love you can feel it
[Music]
if you want to see our last Arizona
Adventure check the video right there
next to us I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe I will see you
there